[Música]
y comenzamos directo a donde conectamos
con londres y es que allí está nuestra
corresponsal luisa pulido en irlanda del
norte hubo elecciones autonómicas para
elegir a los miembros de la asamblea
todo apunta a que por primera vez en la
historia el partido nacionalista sinn
fein que promueve la separación del
reino unido- sería el colectivo con más
escaños mientras los conteos de los
votos continúan hasta el sábado sinn
fein ya aseguró 16 de los 90 puestos
parlamentarios y podría sacar hasta 28
lo que haría que el primer ministro
fuera de este partido que estuvo ligado
al grupo irá durante el conflicto armado
luisa bienvenida a directo américa como
lo decíamos los resultados en irlanda
del norte muestran una tendencia al
primer gobierno republicano nacionalista
que detalles tiene
aunque las 90 sillas de la asamblea de
irlanda del norte no están decididas en
su totalidad si hay una tendencia que
muestra que el sinn fein está en camino
de convertir y de formar el primer
gobierno republicano nacionalista en la
historia de esta región británica sería
un triunfo histórico sin duda porque
esta zona ha sido tradicionalmente por
cien años unionista es decir quiere
estar dentro del reino unido- este
triunfo del sinn fein trae consigo
preguntas
importantísimas sobre el futuro y la
estabilidad del reino unido- como unión
porque el sinn fein podría buscar en el
futuro un referendo para la
reunificación de la isla de irlanda lo
que significa necesariamente que irlanda
del norte salga del reino unido- se
independice este es una probabilidad que
hace varios años sería impensable lo
cierto es que también los nacionalistas
escoceses que arrasaron también en las
elecciones municipales
buscan entretanto la posibilidad de un
segundo referéndum para independizarse
también del reino unido
y como ustedes lo decía también hubo
elecciones municipales en el resto del
reino unido aunque los conservadores
perdieron varios puestos los resultados
no son tan malos para el primer ministro
boris johnson que por ahora siguen no es
así
los resultados han sido un golpe para el
primer ministro boris johnson para su
partido el conservador pero lo cierto es
que no fue una catástrofe como habían
advertido analistas y las encuestas así
que por ahora los diputados
conservadores no llamarían no
convocarían una moción de confianza en
su líder para obligarlo a dar un paso al
costado así que boris johnson por ahora
sigue frente al gobierno en downing
street lo cierto es que ese malestar
popular por el partido y la crisis
política que ha generado el aumento en
el costo de vida en el país no se
tradujo en un voto castigo tal y como se
había advertido pero lo cierto es que el
partido conservador perdió frente al
laborismo el más grande en oposición
tres bastiones electorales tradicionales
aquí en londres son ellos westminster
donde está ubicado el parlamento
británico wandsworth en el suroeste de
la ciudad y barnett tradicionalmente
conservador porque de ahí era diputada
la ex primera ministra margaret thatcher
como les digo por el johns o por ahora
se mantiene en su cargo pero lo cierto
es y aunque posición son ha dicho que
esta jornada fue difícil es que el
primer ministro todavía no puede
respirar tranquilo porque las
investigaciones sobre su gobierno
continúan sobre este escándalo del
partido luisa gracias por toda esta
información y nosotros seguimos con más
en france 24